ça nous est tous arrivé savez quand ils
vous disent ouais l'avion c'est mort
vous ça vous est déjà réglé isabelle
morini-bosc m est déjà arrivé oui merci
non je suis tout seul mais c'est moi je
suis toujours en avance mais quand on
est avec quelqu'un qui est
systématiquement retard j'ai un ami
journaliste qui était système est
d'ailleurs temps mais de trois quarts
d'heure ah ouais et qui vous dit en plus
garder mes bagages donc nous aurait pas
abandonner les bagages etc ça c'est un
cauchemar absolu
sauf est une bonne émission aujourd'hui
vous vous êtes déjà il ya deux semaines
quoi se marrer
si je partais au maroc mais dites-moi
partie de toutes les semaines
ouais c'est que c'est vrai pas sur mon
jeu je bouge un petit peu après il est
clair qu'il est mal payé logis mais non
mais non j'étais des ratés il a raison
je suis bien c'est un truc de fou
quand j'étais pas la peine de préciser
qu'il était invité c'est la cuisse et en
plus grande barre deux fois les montants
avant ce jeu les prendre un café j'ai
discuté j'étais au téléphone
tout d'un coup je regarde leur vie mais
je vais au maroc j'arrive ici finit
jamais
[Rires]
et même aéroport quant à deux heures
d'avancé
tu as l'air aux portes à 12 heures
d'avancé tu as toujours une estrade le
louper tu crois toujours qu'il vont
taper un moment quand autant monsieur
hanouna monsieur hanouna moi ça m'arrive
de plein de fois ils m'appellent échoira
sera de ouf les mecs qui vont partir
sans moi moi j'ai jamais raté un avion
chez toujours way vaut aussi tiré mon
regard est toujours en avance
en revanche je me suis écrasé mes
bagages par un avion et à des reports et
monsieur moreau je revenais de rome pour
un séminaire de notre grande société où
on lagardère et j'étais le dernier sur
le tapis avec quelqu'un que vous
connaissez qui s'appellera mesure
n'était comme de s'apprend patron du
groupe lagardère
bah du coup mon bagage une monade puis
après ils m'ont appelé m'ont dit
monsieur on a retrouvé deux nouvelles
une bonne et une mauvaise la retrouver
vos gardes bagages oui très bien la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'elle a été
écrasée et donc ils m'ont rendu un truc
complètement rasé et alors et vous allez
vous remplacer
il me remplacer la bagages mais pas
l'intérieur puisque c'était que des
fringues j'avais pu ne pas vous vous
étiez plutôt tranquille rare on a on a
mr scoumoune avoue qu est ce qui vous
est arrivé je me suis fait voler mes
bagages mais devant moi non le gars est
passé avec mes bagages devant moi j'ai
dit mais il me vole mes bagages et l'eau
vous n'avez rien fait rien fait n'a pas
réellement sidéré que le gars me vols
des bagages qui dit [ __ ] il me vole
mes bagages
le temps de réaction quand même c'est
dans quoi elle donc essayer de marquer
avec mes deux valises en plus
ah ouais mais oui ils avaient tous nos
sacs j'ai alors moi je monte ma femme
mais y'a un mec je vous justifiez dans
le rer n'était pas capable de courir
travaux lancés bagages étaient il ya
très longtemps là il a changé depuis att
mans moto les deux
[Rires]
c'est super bizarre s'est jamais
retrouvé quoi j'ai dit à ma compagne on
vient de nous voler les magazines était
content a rien fait j'ai dit banon le
gars est parti avec un expert de fou
mais ça ça n'arrive qu'à vous ça